the jurogan experience do you ever do a
demographic breakdown
of who watched like does netflix have a
democrat demographic breakdown of who
watches
those crime shows because it's mostly
women isn't it
anecdotally that's what everybody says
there was a funny bit on saturday night
live
the other night that was like you know
what what do ladies do when they're home
alone you know wait wait wait you know
then they like throw on the murder shows
yeah why is that i don't know it's a
weird thing and when we were making
night stalker
there would like we would get to the the
point in the interview where it's
finally
you know i would i would ask everybody
like okay so
for some reason or another this guy
becomes like the jim morrison of serial
killers
because like when he's paraded through
the courtroom
all of a sudden he's got these like
groupies and fans and they're sending
him and i had gotten access to
all of the like naked pictures that the
girls are sending in
you know because this author had written
a book about him had all this stuff and
i was like
and you always have to kind of ask that
awkward question of like
so why does this guy become this sort of
crazy sex symbol
object of des you know obscure object of
desire
and it's always like kind of
particularly with the you know the the
women who are being interviewed but
everybody
and nobody quite has an answer is it the
bad boy thing
is it the celebrity thing but this is
somebody that like
you know i think as one of the people
said this is somebody that would eat you
for dinner not like
you know there's no it's craziness to
have any attraction to it but yet it
exists
you know this guy has like groupies and
fans and it's very common for murderers
to get
murders of women to get all these
propositions from women
yeah very strange super strange and you
know i
read something about that no you know
whitney cummings was actually telling me
about this
she said she she read that it was
something that had to do with
there was like a an evolutionary benefit
to getting close to killers
like that i think this is theoretical in
what regard that the idea
of it's very hard to kill someone
once you have like human personal
contact is that what you're saying
no no no no the the act of killing
someone
that it's difficult to do and that it
requires like someone who
is to be capable of taking another
person's life
and to be close to that person means
somehow or another you're protected by
them
and that they're they're willing to kill
and that
this is like something that existed
thousands and thousands of years ago in
our dna this desire to be close to
killers
because you were more likely to survive
because there were so many killers
like if you went back in time you know a
few thousand years ago
murder must have been like really common
like when when people were sword
fighting all the time and
dude there's a crazy there's a crazy
book on this stephen pinker wrote this
book called the better angels of our
nature
and what he does is he tracks over time
kind of
the nature of violence in humanity yes
and
he's like okay once upon a time there's
kane and abel
and kane kills abel like the murder rate
is like 50
so actually we've been trending up ever
since then and
like it literally looks at how you know
over time
the incidence of like violence has
actually even though it doesn't seem
like that
dramatically decreased it does seem like
that
it does seem like that i think we just
focus on
the instances of violence because we
have mass media
right and it's fascinating yeah and if
it bleeds it leads
so but why is that you know like that's
something that
you know making the night stalker or
even making silk road
it's like why are we fascinated by the
underworld
you know the sort of like the worst
things that people do to each other
like what is it you know and and i'm
you're participating in it i'm
participating
anytime we're watching it making it or
whatever
you know we are all in some way
complicit in that
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video and audio experience on
spotify you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience